okay
here we are in overtime i was just
offering
we've already given away two of the
items would you like the p-tape would
you like the trump penis pump i guess i
gotta step off stage and call my wife
would you like the uh receipt for
melania how about that for uh
all right so where are the okay here we
here we are cracker barrel recently
announced a new plant-based
fake meat option
really
hey at their restaurants as a vegan
oh this is for you you're a vegan i'm a
pescetarian but i'm i i know that that's
somewhere that we might have so you just
kill fish it's fine
yeah i think
their motto a little murder uh
uh
as a pescetarian i'll change that too do
you think america will ever be ready for
a meatless future you know i don't i
don't like the veganism that is like
evangelizing it to other people i don't
believe in mandating it but i do believe
that with technology and also with our
environmental constraints and how much
how much land and water and resources
goes into meat and our growing
population at the same time that a shift
that way organically i think is a
healthy and probably inevitable thing
well
certainly we eat too much meat yeah
definitely the inconvenient truth about
me
i think is that
although it's a disaster for the planet
and certainly not good for the animals
who get killed
it may not be bad for us
depending on who you are what your
composition is how much you eat but
there is there is just not definitive
science as we were talking about really
about almost did you ever see a happy
vegan ever
yes
yes seriously
they're always always hangry aren't they
no that is not true they see you eating
a steak stop it that is you know what it
is they just want a steak no that is not
true but what we need what we need is
the that's not true the kevin costner
character in yellowstone when he has a
little uh romantic entanglement with an
animal rights activist he gives her a
long speech about how the process of
agricultural turbines kills immense
numbers of voles and mice and so on
anyway i can't deliver that speech but
that's that's what that's what you need
crossfire is a production versus taking
an animal rearing it and then allowing
it to be used for its entire lifespan
also factory farming yeah it's one thing
to eat meat it's another thing to
torture animals on the weight that is
not necessary people didn't used to do
that 100 years ago there wasn't factory
farming more than 90 of the meat that we
consume from supermarkets i only eat
meat from an animal that died of natural
causes
[Applause]
resting comfortably after a long illness
at cedar
those are the only animals
the trump
appears
if trump had not blown up at you after
learning about your negative comments of
it would you still be open to being his
friend you interviewed trump recently
down at lagos i did four months ago yeah
yeah and he walked away i've only had
the nuclear football sitting there
either probably not gone
it was quite funny because the interview
was quite fractious in parts and then he
would be quite friendly and then quite
francis
because he'd been sent a whole load of
things i've said about him uh just
before the interview and he called me
out to his office and he was like
meeting like al pacino and the godfather
he had this bit of paper and he was like
you called me a mob boss
you called me a gangster you said i
should never run for office again why
should i do this effing interview well
he had it on a piece of paper we had
someone to send well you know you know
who used to do that yeah at the end
frank sinatra yeah
really he would have a list oh
he was too old to remember who he hated
yeah
really so they were not kidding about
this he would put down the this broad
this stupid broads
you know and then he would just be it
was the same thing it was quite funny
the way i turned it around was he'd um i
said to him look it's not all going to
be back i was trying to say the
interview and he said well what do you
mean i said well i want to talk about
your hole-in-one last week at golf
oh it was a great shot i went i know i
know i said um
i said have you seen the interview with
ernie else in the palm beach gazette
whatever it was and he'd just come out
he said ernie and he gave an interview
because he played with him he said no
what did he say i said he said you were
the best presidential golfer he'd ever
played with he said it was a brilliant
shot it was a five iron into the wind
bang bang straight in the hole he said
it was fantastic he went all right i'll
do the interview
yeah
and that is donald trump
and that is all you need to know about
donald trump
donald trump correct he is a sick man he
has this disease called malignant
narcissism it's it's really in the book
of crazy i mean and and he's got the
worst case of it that's that explains
putin it explains why he doesn't
anything bad about the kkk or whoever
likes him he will automatically like you
yeah i remember he said it in the
campaign putin said it was brilliant i
think i'll take the compliment
that's it
putin said i was brilliant
done
ross why is lyme disease ignored by the
media and medical establishment despite
nearly half a million americans being
diagnosed each year would you say it's a
silent epidemic well i think we kind of
kind of i mean well you know lyme
patients actually tend to complain a lot
so it's not it's not completely it's not
complicated
it's not silent at all it's just not
well
researched and and treated and we don't
know very much right and we were you
know we were talking about all the
limits of modern medicine but the thing
that you have to keep in mind in defense
of
all those doctors who saw me and
couldn't diagnose me is it sounds really
weird right you're telling me you know
you were bitten by a tick and it gave
you this condition and it doesn't follow
any particular patterns and one day your
foot hurts and the next day your chest
hurts and the next day you're gagging up
your breakfast it sounds a little weird
and there's also a cycle that happens
with with these kind with when when
you're a person who has an experience
like this right and you realize that you
know you have a problem that the system
can't can't fix right you get tugged
into weird places and suddenly you're
saying well you know if the people
outside the establishment are right
about lyme disease about how to treat
chronic lyme disease maybe they're right
about chemtrails maybe they're right
about bigfoot and the next time you see
your doctor you start talking to him
about bigfoot and he's like oh another
lyme disease patient with a bigfoot
obsession right i said no no no it's a
terrible analogy
it is
i'm sorry but the human body is still a
mystery we're still at the infancy of
understanding you know they don't know
why tylenol works they don't know why
anesthesia works
tylenol would never get approved by the
fda
today why it's too isn't it too
carcinogenic it's it's too uh this is
why yeah it's it's over the counter in
the us but not the other countries
though thailand tylenol is i think i
think that you know what i'm going to
define do you want to refrain from
displaying displaying ignorance and well
let people take their talents i'm just
saying
yes there's definitely something i don't
know i mean yeah there's definitely one
of those things
do your own research i'm an amazing
big tylenol
[Applause]
you i mean you look so healthy after so
much antibiotics that amazes me because
i mean antibiotics i'm very glad they
exist in this world i mean before
antibiotics you could die from a
splinter
now we're almost going to enter a phase
of history where we may not have
antibiotics because we've overused them
so much but they do incredible damage
when you're on oh yeah again like any
medicine there is a no no and lots of
did you have antibiotics i was i was
increasing i was incredibly lucky i had
very
i took i didn't just take antibiotics
for six years at various points i was
taking like
12 pills a day 15 pills a day and i
never had you know a lot of people their
you know pals can't handle it and
they're this is you know again one of
the many reasons people struggle with
these illnesses is because if you have
to take antibiotics for months or years
it just becomes something that people
just yeah absolutely can't handle but
this is the weird irony of lyme disease
is that we're used to a world where
people are worried about doctors over
prescribing antibiotics before i got
lyme disease i was like oh doctors
they'll give you an antibiotic for
anything right and then
you have lyme disease they give you two
weeks of antibiotics and you're like
begging you're like could i just have
one more week of antibiotics like no
absolutely absolutely not what are you
crazy you're going to be dealing
doxycycline behind the hospital i know
you are
well i'm just glad as i said before i'm
going to reiterate that's the headline
tonight for me i'm so glad you're you're
back and you're healthy and that's what
important and i give the credit to jesus
amen thank you very much
you